hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
it's coming up on that time of the year
again where we wait for Samsung's
stepchild Android flagship lineup to get
updated obviously it gets overshadowed a
lot by the Galaxy S line cuz that's
really their main flagship lineup but us
geeks know about the Galaxy Note lineup
it's really where it's at it's usually
the spec King which is really why we
like it so much but there are a ton of
other reasons why it delivers an awesome
experience for people who want a big
juiced up Android phone and guess what
we already kind of know the specs of the
new Galaxy Note 4 I'll leave the link
right below the like button for the
source it's one of the most reliable
sources out there that's given us the
sort of information so the note for
being a big phone we're expecting it to
have big time specs and a stylus but the
number one thing I'm excited for on this
spec sheet is it looks like it's going
to have the Snapdragon 805 chip from
Qualcomm a lot of the most recent
flagships up to like right now have been
powered by the Snapdragon 801 chip which
is another great processor and it's it's
not like bad or anything but we haven't
really seen the real power of the
Snapdragon 805 chip yet so it's been
mostly hyped basically up until this
point so it seems like the perfect chip
to power the new quad HD display yes
we're going that if you've seen my
videos about the LG g3 you already know
that it's one of the first smartphones
to rock that 2560 by 1440 resolution an
absurd sharp pixel density for a smart
phone display and not to be outdone in
the spec department the Galaxy Note 4 is
going to have that same resolution we
don't know what size yet but it will
also be an AMOLED display so it'll have
the pitch black blacks the absurd
contrast ratio is the typical
oversaturated Samsung style and it's
gonna be an incredibly vivid and sharp
display and I'm really pumped to see
what that looks like obviously also
being an AMOLED display you'll have room
to do some cool lockscreen features some
nifty pixel lighting or not lighting
tricks the same way the Moto X did so
there's a lot of room for some crazy
awesome features here with a display
like this it'll also pack a 16 megapixel
Sony made camera sensor that's also
already used in a couple of other
flagships right now it's really good
we've seen the results of it and other
great phones and it'll also have up
image stabilization so no complaints
with what we're gonna see out of the
camera quality and then I'm going to
assume that it'll continue the trend of
having an absurd amount of RAM so three
gigabytes maybe even four and I'm going
to assume that it'll continue the trend
of having a massive battery because the
phone this big always has a huge battery
at least three thousand milliamp hours
probably more and this one is also going
to come out after Google i/o so on the
other side of potentially a new version
of Android being released and if it does
happen then I would expect this phone to
be one of the first to be updated to it
if not already having it out the box so
what it really comes down to for me is
what it looks like
the design so the Samsung Galaxy s5
right now is most recent flagship from
Samsung it's what they've spent a lot of
time on and focus on it's an interesting
design is probably not the favorite of a
lot of people it's definitely it's got
these dimples in the back a lot of
people have very mixed thoughts on the
way it looks but really before this
phone came out a lot of Samsung's
flagship s-- we're moving towards the
look that we see with the Galaxy Note 3
and a whole bunch of other stuff where
they have this soft touch leatherette
sort of back and then this stitching all
around the sides I'm not sure what to
expect from the design of the note 4 I'm
really hoping that it's somewhere in
between where it has a premium look and
feel obviously Samsung doesn't actually
use these metals or premium materials
but they often mask it with things that
look like premium material is actually
kind of feel all right in the hand as
long as they're not slippery plastic so
again I don't know what to expect with
it here but I'm fully expecting it to
look like something better than it
actually is so my only real concern here
is how big the phone is actually
physically going to be and looking at
the note series if you look at the
history of it this phone has always been
big the original Galaxy Note was a
monster at five point three inches the
Galaxy Note 2 was a monster when it came
out with a 5.5 inch display and the
Galaxy Note 3 we have now a monster with
a 5.7 inch display math would seem to
indicate that we're going to get
something around a 5.9 inch display with
the Galaxy Note 4 but it doesn't have to
be I'm really liking the trend with
smartphones now where we're moving
towards these thinner bezels again you
see a prime example with the LG g3 where
they could use another five
point seven inch panel but just thin out
the bezels a bit and make the phone more
comfortable to feel and hold in the hand
obviously a big 5.7 inch quad-hd display
isn't going to seem nearly as weirdly as
some of the other smaller flag ships but
you know Samsung can decide to get on
that train if they want to really I
don't have any idea what the note 4 is
going to look like in the design
department but another thing that I was
concerned with and it's probably more of
a long shot than anything else is this
storage I'm seeing a more and more
demand where people realize that it
doesn't actually cost a hundred bucks
more to make a phone with double the
storage a 32 gigabyte phone doesn't cost
a hundred bucks less than a 64 gigabyte
phone to make so people are more and
more requesting to give the baseline
price for a 32 gigabyte phone and have a
64 gigabyte phone be a plus $20 option
that would be nice if Samsung can give
us at least a 32 gigabyte option
hopefully 64 gig and maybe like I said
longshot 128 gig galaxy note 4 I'm also
expecting him to keep expandable storage
like they have with the other notes so
it's probably not a big deal if they
keep that microSD card slot which is
something to keep an eye on so yeah I am
pretty excited for the Galaxy Note 4 and
all the beastly specs behind the awesome
display we're expecting and I'm pretty
hyped about this new phone even if it's
before anyone else's yet
kind of like I was last year for the
Galaxy Note 3 to come out and also I
know I asked for a Google Play edition
of everything and we didn't even really
see one now yet with the Galaxy s5 but
if we saw a Google Play edition Galaxy
Note 4 that'll be pretty awesome that's
probably the biggest longshot of
everything I've said this video so
either way yeah if you guys have any
other thoughts about the note 4 what you
want to see leave that in the comments
section below you'll probably see me
answering a bunch of them and I will
talk to you guys the next one hope you
enjoyed bass
[Music]